hallo mein Name ist Sky du Mont und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
willkommen bei der heutigen Episode
unseres Tatort Deutschland Spezials mein
Name ist Natalie Strauß und ich bin
Radiomoderatorin und True Crime Fan der
heutige Fall findet in meiner
Heimatstadt Hamburg statt und lässt mich
bis heute nicht mehr los wir reißen in
die 80er und keiner kann das Gefühl von
damals besser beschreiben als mein
lieber Sprecher und moderationskollege
Mirko Kasimir bist nämlich schon ein
zweijährchen älter als ich wo willst du
das denn wissen
es ist der Hochsommer 1986 ein Dienstag
in Bonn regiert eine Koalition aus
cdu/csu und FDP unter Bundeskanzler
Helmut Kohl Kapitän der deutschen
Fußballnationalmannschaft ist Klaus
ahlofs die Reaktorkatastrophe von
Tschernobyl liegt gerade einmal drei
Monate zurück und zwei Tage zuvor ist
das bis dahin größte Rockkonzert der
deutschen Geschichte zu Ende gegangen
ein Protest Festival gegen die
umstrittene Wiederaufbereitungsanlage
Wackersdorf mit über 100.000 Besuchern
auf Platz 1 in den Charts stehen Level
42 mit lessons in Love dahinter tummeln
sich Falko Hubert Kah Sandra Samantha
Fox und McDonald's verliere der Woche
ist Modern Talking abgestiegen von Platz
6 auf Platz 15 mit Atlantis ist calling
es so heißt for Love
ja ja danke für den Ohrwurm Liebe Mirko
den werde ich jetzt den ganzen Tag im
Kopf haben
der
29.07.86 ist jedenfalls so 80er wie ein
Tag nur sein kann und das Verbrechen
besser gesagt die Verbrechen über die
wir heute sprechen die konnten auch nur
so in den 80ern stattfinden Mirko erzähl
mal
das Polizeipräsidium Hamburg ein
schmuckloses Hochhaus am Berliner Tor im
Stadtteil St Georg ragt 85 Meter in den
strahlenden Sommerhimmel die Polizisten
Beamten und Angestellten die hier ihren
Dienst verrichten können dem schönen
Wetter aber nur wenig abgewinnen die
Klimaanlage und die Ventilatoren auf dem
Schreibtisch und kommen nicht gegen die
Hitze an schon an normalen Tagen ist es
um die Frischluft Zufuhr in den Büros
nicht dazu gut bestellt das sind den
meisten Zimmern ein Aschenbecher genauso
zur Ausstattung gehört wie die
Schreibmaschine tut ein Übriges zur
dicken Luft
der Mann der an diesem Vormittag in
Begleitung von Polizisten und seiner
Ehefrau des Gebäude betritt stört das
alles nicht im geringsten wo er herkommt
gibt es statt dicker Luft gesiebte Luft
er sitzt in Untersuchungshaft und alles
ist besser als seine kleine Zelle in der
Haftanstalt
dieser Mann heißt Werner Pinzner er hat
eine Verabredung mit dem Staatsanwalt
pfingstner hat große Enthüllungen und
ein umfassendes Geständnis angekündigt
vor seinem Transport ins
Polizeipräsidium ist Werner Pinzner
gründlich durchsucht worden auch seine
Ehefrau wird durchsucht zwei
Polizeibeamte führen die beiden sowie
pinsters Rechtsanwältin schließlich ins
Zimmer 418 im Sicherheitstrakt im
vierten Stock des Gebäudes wo
Staatsanwalt Wolfgang Petry ihn mit
Kaffee und belegten Brötchen erwartet
finster soll sich wohlfühlen und
Vertrauen haben und so beginnt bistri
die Vernehmung dann auch mit einem
lockeren Spruch
nun schießen sie mal los
kurz darauf für dein Schuss
das kannst du dir nicht ausdenken in dem
Film wäre das jetzt ein ganz schlechter
geschmackloser und äußerst billiger Witz
wird maximal für Augenrollen sorgen aber
solche Geschichten schreibt echt nur das
Leben
drei Schüsse fallen an diesem Tag im
Zimmer 418 drei Menschen sterben aber am
besten gehen wir noch einmal ein paar
Jahre zurück Mirko wer war Werner
Pinzner
wir gehen zurück ins Jahr 1947 da wird
Werner pinsner als Sohn einer
Verkäuferin und eines
rundfunkmechanikers geboren die Schule
bricht er ab und schlägt sich mit
diversen Jobs durchs Leben unter anderem
als Fahrer Fliesenleger Schlachter zwei
Jahre fährt er zur See eine
Verpflichtung als Berufssoldat scheitert
an vor Strafen wegen kleiner Delikte
1970 wird er zu einer ersten kurzen
Freiheitsstrafe verurteilt
im Jahr darauf bringt seine erste
Ehefrau ihre gemeinsame Tochter Birgit
zur Welt doch ein Leben in beengten
klammen Verhältnissen zwischen
Gelegenheits Jobs und Kleinkriminalität
kommt für Künstler nicht in Frage es
wird Zeit für größeres und schreckliches
1975 beteiligt er sich an einem
Raubüberfall auf einen Supermarkt der
Überfall geht gründlich schief einer von
pinsners Komplizen erschießt den
Filialleiter der erste von vielen Toten
auf pinsners weg
die Bande wird gefasst Pinzner kommt mit
einer Haftstrafe von zehn Jahren davon
da ihm keine direkte Beteiligung an der
Tötung nachgewiesen werden kann und hier
kommt er für mich unglaublichste Teil
der ganzen Geschichte man sollte ja
meinen jetzt sitzt der Mann erstmal im
Gefängnis die Welt hat 10 Jahre vor ihm
Ruhe aber ganz im Gegenteil im Knast
hebt pinzen das kriminelle Karriere
richtig ab der Hintergrund ist es gab
damals zahlreiche und auch dringend
notwendige Reform im Strafe Zug der
Fokus sollte mehr auf Resozialisierung
liegen ist ja erstmal total gut und der
richtige Hintergedanke aber in der
Ausführung ging es in manchen Fällen
deutlich zu weit mehr damals waren die
Verhältnisse noch etwas anders Drogen
und sogar Waffen sind leicht zu
organisieren der Austausch mit Komplizen
in Freiheit ist kein Problem
in Haft kommt Werner pinster in Kontakt
mit dem Rotlichtmilieu im Kiez auf St
Pauli hat man immer Verwendung für
jemanden der scheinbar keines Skrupel
hat und für Geld und Anerkennung alles
zu tun bereit ist dass derjenige gerade
im Knast sitzt muss nicht unbedingt ein
Hindernis sein
der Zeitpunkt könnte nicht günstiger
sein für Werner Pinzner denn nicht nur
der Strafvollzug befindet sich im
Umbruch sondern auch die Szene auf St
Pauli letztere allerdings nicht unter
dem Vorzeichen der
Menschenfreundlichkeit ganz im Gegenteil
die gute alte Zeit auf dem Kiez ist
vorbei bis heute erzählen ehemalige
kiezgrößen von jener Zeit in der es
einen Kodex für die Juden gab in der man
Unstimmigkeit mit Fäusten statt Pistolen
regelte und das große Geld mit Sex
gemacht wurde naja da muss man jetzt
aber auch ein bisschen abwägen das ist
natürlich Gangster Romantik ja ist ja
schön für die Kerle das ist da so ein
Ehrenkodex gegeben hat und so weiter
aber wenn wir mal ehrlich sind es ging
schon immer dreckig so und wichtig ist
zu sagen dieser Ehrenkodex der galt zum
Beispiel nicht für den Umgang mit
Prostituierten für die gab es niemals so
etwas wie die gute alte Zeit in der
alles rosig und einfach war da hast du
vollkommen Recht die gute alte Zeit galt
wohl hauptsächlich für die die dabei
ohne nicht auf Verluste ordentlich
verdient haben in den 80ern jedenfalls
verschlimmert sich die Situation
dramatisch schuld daran sind das
HIV-Virus und Kokain die Angst vor Aids
lässt das Geschäft mit dem käuflichen
Sex Einbrechen der Handel mit Drogen
wird zu einer immer wichtigeren
Einkommensquelle doch damit kommen neue
Player ins Spiel der Konkurrenz kam wird
immer brutaler und damit schlägt die
Stunde für Werner Pinzner den man der
bald als St Pauli Killer bekannt werden
sollte
1984 Pinzner ist offiziell noch in Haft
verübt er als Freigänger einen Überfall
auf einen Geldtransporter und
schließlich seinen ersten Mord im
Auftrag von Peter nussa bekannt als der
Wiener Peter und Mitglied einer Bande
die sich nach der Bar in der Sie sich
trifft die Chicago Bande nennt soll er
einen ehemaligen Bordellbesitzer
einschüchtern
hat Kokain Schulden und versucht Wiener
Peter zu erpressen
Pinzner soll ihm einen fingerabschneiden
und dafür 40.000 Mark bekommen
also sagte es später bei der Polizei aus
antwortet ja ach ich geh da hoch und
knall ihn weg
am 7 juli 1984 stirbt arsy durch Schüsse
aus einem Revolver der Marke Arminius
den sich pinsner besorgt hat der St
Pauli Killer kehrt nach seinem ersten
Mord zurück in den offenen Vollzug der
Justizvollzugsanstalt Vierlande und
verstaut die Tatwaffe dort in einem
Schließfach
das mag man gar nicht glauben ja aber
das war Teil der Reform im Strafvollzug
jeder Häftling hatte ein persönliches
Schließfach dass die Justiz keinen
Einblick nehmen durfte die Maßnahme
sollte Vertrauen zeigen und Vertrauen
schaffen
ja zumindest in diesem Fall wurde dieses
Vertrauen auf die denkbar schlimmste
atmes braucht nach seiner Freilassung
wird pinsner Mucki wie auf St Pauli
genannt wird zum Mann fürs Grobe in der
Chicago Bande wenn Wiener Peter Streit
hat sich hintergangen fühlt oder wenn
ein Konkurrenz zu lästig wird schickt
der pinsner und der Regel das auf sehr
endgültige Weise innerhalb weniger
Monate sterben mindestens vier Szene
Größen durch seine Hand am 12 September
84 wird Peter Feilmeier bekannt als
Bayern Peter erschossen Lackschuh Dieter
Dietmar Traub stirbt am 13 November
Ostern 1985 tötet er die
Bordellbetreiber Waldemar Dammer und
Ralf kühne in der Szene bekannt unter
dem Namen corvettenreich diese ganzen
Spitznamen die Klingen natürlich immer
total niedlich und lustig aber da ist
überhaupt gar nichts lustig die ganze
Geschichte kommt mir echt vor wie im
Schlechten Film bis heute ist nämlich
nicht sicher wie viele Menschen Pins
nach wirklich auf dem Gewissen hat
vermutlich sind es 14 Menschen oder
anders gesagt 12 zum Zeitpunkt seiner
Verhaftung 86 aber Mirko wie kam man den
Künstler am Ende auf die Schliche tja
ganz einfach weil Werner pinsner
unvorsichtig wird er fühlt sich einfach
zu sicher unter anderem weil er sich
verliebt hat klingt jetzt erstmal nach
einem sehr menschlichen Hintergrund aber
du meinst natürlich nicht die Liebe zu
seiner zweiten Frau Jutta richtig nein
die meine ich nicht vielleicht ist
verliebt auch einen zu starkes Wort aber
Tatsache ist dass er offensichtlich eine
sehr starke Bindung
naja kann man schon sagen eine Bindung
hat nämlich zu seiner Tatwaffe seinem
Revolver der Marke Arminius Ermittler
berichten später dass er bei
Vernehmungen stets liebevoll von der
Waffe sprach
Pinzner setzt den Revolver bei all
seinen Morden ein und so können mittels
ballistische Untersuchungen die Morde
einem einzigen Täter zugeordnet werden
die Polizei gründet eine
Sonderkommission und setzt alles daran
den Täter zu finden dafür wurden
verdeckter Ermittler ins Milieu
eingeschläust und die Ergebnisse zu
allen Fällen wurden systematisch
zusammengetragen
1 Szene Insider liefert schließlich den
entscheidenden Hinweis am 15 April nimmt
ein Einsatzkommando der Polizei Pinzner
und seinen Auftraggeber Peter Nusser
Wiener Peter fest
ein Zitat aus dem Protokoll der
Festnahme
auf dem Sofa des Killers lag die
Mordwaffe eingeladener Revolver der
Marke Arminius Kaliber 38
ende gut alles gut denkste in Haft
behauptet finster nämlich auspacken zu
wollen er sagt er sei immer gefürchtet
aber nie richtig respektiert worden und
das macht sein Ego aber nicht mit er
gesteht seine Taten liefert
Informationen aber nur scheibchenweise
und das macht den Staatsanwalt langsam
echt ungeduldig denn alles nur in
kleinen Häppchen macht keinen Spaß am
29.07 soll es dann endlich die große
Aussage geben seine Frau Jutta soll
dabei sein das hat er sich ausgehandelt
aber jetzt müssen wir noch mal über eine
andere Frau sprechen Mirko seine
Anwältin
ja und dabei ist zu beachten dass der
Name der Anwältin nicht öffentlich
genannt werden darf die Frau ist damals
relativ jung und ihr neuer Mandant
Werner pintzner einen wirklich großer
Fang ein mehrfacher Mörder und auch das
ist wichtig seit seiner Verhaftung eine
Berühmtheit die mit den Medien genauso
spielt wie mit dem Staatsanwalt ein Fall
der ihrer Karriere einen großen Schub
verschaffen kann doch es kommt alles
anders die Anwältin hat selbst große
Probleme in einer Ehe mit einem
psychisch Kranken Ehemann sie verfällt
ihre Mandanten und gerät in eine
seltsame Dreiecksbeziehung mit ihm und
seiner Frau Jutta mit der sie sich zu
identifizieren scheint die Anwältin
beginnt für ihren Mandanten Drogen in
den Knast zu schmuggeln und schließlich
lässt sie sich auch auf seine letzte
Forderung ein
sie besorgt eine Waffe ein Revolver der
Marke Smith and Wesson nicht pinsners
geliebter Arminius aber genauso tödlich
jetzt drängt sich natürlich die Frage
auf wie kommt eine junge aufstrebende
Anwältin an so einem Punkt da können wir
nur spekulieren wir können der Frau
nicht in den Kopf schauen vielleicht hat
ihre bereits kaputte Ehe da auch mit
reingespielt auf jeden Fall hat er sie
Schritt für Schritt immer mehr
reingezogen und als sie dann sogar so
weit war ihn Drogen in den Knast zu
schmuggeln war sie natürlich erpressbar
und komplett in seiner Hand vielleicht
glaubte sie diesen Weg jetzt weitergehen
zu müssen aber wie gesagt da können wir
tatsächlich nur spekulieren aber diese
Fakten stehen fest sie hat die Waffe
besorgt und pinzen aus Frau dabei
geholfen sie in ihrem Slip zu verstecken
und ins Polizeipräsidium zu schmuggeln
seine Frau Jutta geht kurz auf Toilette
holt sie aus dem Slip und steckt sie in
ihre Handtasche dann im Zimmer 418
reicht sie den Revolver einen Smith &
Wesson an ihren Mann weiter
anwesend sind neben Pinzner seiner
Ehefrau der Anwältin und Staatsanwalt
bistri auch dies die nur die pistin
Gitta Berger und zwei Polizisten na dann
schießen sie mal los beginnt bistri die
Vernehmung im nächsten Moment sieht
Pinzner den Revolver so meine Herren das
ist eine Geiselnahme ruft er Petry
springt auf und pinsner schießt
zwei Schüsse treffen den Staatsanwalt in
Kopf und Oberkörper erbricht zusammen
die beiden Polizeibeamten fliehen aus
dem Zimmer pfingstner schießt ihnen
hinterher doch sie entkommen unverletzt
die Protokollantin Dieter Berger
verkriecht sich unter einem Schreibtisch
Werner Pinzner verbarrikadiert die Tür
mit einem Tisch dann ruft er seine
Tochter an
örge dich liebe dich mit diesen Worten
verabschiedet er sich und gibt den
Telefonhörer an seine Frau Jutta weiter
die sagt was jetzt geschieht haben wir
so gewollt nach dem Gespräch kniet sich
seine Frau auf den Boden ihr Mann
steckte den revolverlauf in den Mund ein
weiterer Schussfeld
Jutta pinsner ist sofort tot
gleich darauf schießt sich pinsner
selbst in den Mund und stirbt auf der
Stelle
den beiden anderen Frauen geschieht
nichts
Staatsanwalt biestri er liegt am
nächsten Tag seinen schweren
Verletzungen
boah was für eine Geschichte ich meine
als Hamburgerin kenne ich die ja schon
aber trotzdem jedes Mal aufs Neue Haut
die mich echt um also vermutlich gehen
13 Morde und ein Selbstmord auf pinzen
aus Konto die Tat schockiert die ganze
Nation und hat schließlich auch
politische Folgen in der Tat die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen in den
Gefängnissen und polizeigebäuden werden
massiv kritisiert Rolf lange und Eva
leidhäuser Senatoren für Inneres und
Justiz im Hamburger Senat müssen
zurücktreten und die regierende SPD
verliert die Wahl in Hamburg 1986 vor
Prinz nastaten hat es ganz nach einem
Sieg ausgesehen und der Kiez ja der
berüchtigte und gefürchtete St Pauli
Killer Werner Mucki Pinzner ist tot doch
von Frieden kann keine Rede sein das
Geschäft mit den Drogen und der
Prostitution wird immer brutaler die
vermeintlich guten alten Zeiten sind
endgültig vorbei
Anwältin wird wegen Beihilfe zum Maut zu
einer Haftstrafe von sechseinhalb Jahren
verurteilt Peter Nusser der Wiener Peter
der Auftraggeber pinzners wird zu
lebenslange Haft verurteilt kommt
allerdings schon im Jahr 2000 frei und
wird in sein Heimatland Österreich
abgeschoben verbunden mit der Androhung
er müsste den Rest seiner Strafe
absetzen sollte er jemals wieder nach
Deutschland einreisen tja und im April
letzten Jahres wurde er auf dem
Flughafen Frankfurt am Main erneut
verhaftet und sitzt seitdem wieder ein
es war zwar nur ein kurzer Zwischenstopp
auf der Reise von der Dominikanischen
Republik nach Wien aber er hat einfach
nicht damit gerechnet nach so langer
Zeit im Transit abgefangen zu werden und
damit sind wir am Ende unserer
Geschichte aber Mirko ich habe echt so
viele Fragen tja geht mir genauso ich
komme einfach nicht drüber hinweg wie
einfach diesen Mann gemacht wurde
entschließfach im Gefängnis auf dass die
Justiz keinen Zugriff hat
das ist irgendwie unvorstellbar das lädt
doch gerade zu zu einem Missbrauch ein
der Mann geht zum Freigang raus erledigt
den Auftragsmord und kommt danach
pünktlich und ohne beansteinung zurück
und deponiert die Waffe im Gefängnis ich
weiß nicht das ist irgendwie unfassbar
das ist der bizarste Teil finde ich der
Geschichte obwohl so viele bizarre Teile
gibt ich meine eine Reform des
Strafvollzugs war zwar ganz sicher
notwendig aber da scheint man in einigen
Punkten übers Ziel deutlich
hinausgeschossen zu sein da wurden
Fehler gemacht die am Ende Menschenleben
gekostet haben und nicht nur ein sondern
viele Menschen leben wichtig ist aber
auch Fehler wurden korrigiert und es
wäre so in dieser Form heute nicht mehr
möglich was mich aber auch nicht los
lässt ist diese merkwürdige Dreieck
Beziehung ja die Rolle der beiden Frauen
seiner Ehefrau und der Anwältin die
müssen ja auch irgendwie miteinander
ausgekommen sein also was da los war
frage ich mich auch die müssen ihm ja
total hörig gewesen sein ich meine seine
Frau war ja sogar so weit dass sie ihm
freiwillig in den Tod vorausging nicht
nach sondern sogar voraus aber
vielleicht hat sie auch einfach keinen
anderen Ausweg gesehen ich meine man
muss mal betrachten mit wem sie da
zusammen ist wahrscheinlich hätte sich
am Ende sowieso irgendwer an ihr gerecht
deswegen ist das wohl die einzige Lösung
gewesen aber ich kann es einfach nicht
verstehen dazu müssen wir vielleicht
Schweigen da wir uns jetzt über Personen
unterhalten die sich dazu nicht mal
äußern können und wir können uns nicht
in sie hinein versetzen genau mit diesem
Rätsel müssen wir wohl leben und es
bringt nichts da wild herum zu
spekulieren was mich besonders
fasziniert ist wie sehr dieser Fall mit
der Zeitgeschichte verwoben ist nur ein
kleines banal ist Detail man muss sich
nur mal die Fotos der Beteiligten
anschauen und schon allein deren
schnauzwerte katapultieren also sofort
zurück in die 80er was da alles zusammen
kam ein neuer Blick auf den Strafvollzug
der zu in einigen Fällen völlig
überzogenen Reformen führte der Wandel
von St Pauli von einer ich sag mal trieb
abfuhrstation für Seemänner zu einem
Touristenmagnet das Auftauchen von HIV
und die Welle hat er Drogen die damals
über den Westen hereinbrach der Beginn
der organisierten Kriminalität wie wir
sie heute kennen da haben wir echt
einiges zu verdauen ich meine als
Hamburgerin kenne ich die Geschichte
gefühlt in und auswendig aber sie lässt
mich einfach nicht los also gibt viel
darüber nachzudenken wir danken euch auf
jeden Fall sehr fürs zuhören und hoffen
natürlich dass wir euch keine Uroma im
Kopf gesetzt haben mit Atlantis
escalling
ja genau bloß auf damit Liebe Podcast
Hörerinnen und Hörer wir würden uns
freuen wenn ihr auch bei der nächsten
Folge wieder dabei seid bei Tatort
Deutschland Spezial euer Mirko und eure
Natalie
den Fall des reeperbahnkellers Werner
pinsner zeichnen wir nach mit Artikeln
aus Bild Welt Spiegel und Fokus sowie
dem Dokumentarfilm die großen
Kriminalfälle der St Pauli Killer
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Haier Produktion Marvin schwarz